si hacemos reaccionar un aldehído o
cetona con un exceso de alcohol en un
ambiente ácido formaremos una seta del
lado derecho
tenemos unas et al y como pueden ver
tiene un o herby prima y otro o herby
prima que obtuvo del alcohol también
formaremos agua esta reacción se
encuentra en equilibrio hay muchas cosas
que podemos hacer para que el equilibrio
cambie hacia la derecha y haya más
producción de hace tal es una de ellas
es eliminar el agua cuando se forme así
disminuimos la concentración de este
producto y el equilibrio cambiará
produciéndose más de esto formaremos más
hace tal otra cosa que podríamos hacer
es incrementar la concentración de
algunos de los reactivos al incrementar
la concentración de aldehído
el equilibrio tiende hacia la derecha
formando más productos esta reacción se
hace en un ambiente ácido y como fuente
de protones pueden usar algo como ácido
sulfúrico h2so4 o ácido tolueno
sulfónico ts o h esos son los dos
catalizadores más utilizados para formar
hace tales echemos un vistazo a esta
reacción y después haremos el mecanismo
será un poco largo pero creo que será
más fácil de entender si lo hacemos para
una reacción como ésta tenemos
ciclohexano na reaccionando con etanol
en exceso y usaremos ácido sulfúrico
como nuestro catalizador si observamos
el panorama general podemos predecir
nuestro aceptar pensemos en que esta
porción de la molécula
a nuestro anillo entonces tenemos el
anillo
y por aquí un oxígeno después un grupo r
y por acá un oxígeno y un grupo r ahí
está ese es nuestro producto se ve
chistosa esta molécula pero es una c tal
ahora pensemos en el mecanismo para esta
reacción si tenemos etanol y ácido
sulfúrico lo primero que puede ocurrir
es la protón acción del etanol entonces
mostremos el ión protón ar
esta es una de las cosas que podría
ocurrir primero ya está proto nado y
ahora funcionará como un ácido aquí
tenemos ciclohexano na y un par de
electrones de la ciclohexano na tomarán
un protón del ácido estos electrones se
moverán hacia acá para formar etanol
dibujemos eso el primer paso sería la
protón acción entonces nuestro oxígeno
que aún tiene un par de electrones
libres
pongamos estos electrones en rosa
formaron este enlace lo que le da al
oxígeno una carga formal positiva por
las estructuras de resonancia sabemos
que este carbono se vuelve más electro
físico por lo tanto un núcleo filo
reaccionará con esto y claro el núcleo
filo sería etanol entonces una molécula
de etanol aparece para funcionar como
núcleo filo
un parte electrones libres atacan a
nuestro electro filo empujando a estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno ese sería el
segundo paso el ataque núcleo físico
vamos a escribirlo este fue el paso 1 la
protón acción
paso 2 el ataque núcleo físico y cuando
el núcleo filo ataca nos queda este
oxígeno por aquí que ahora tiene dos
pares de electrones libres estos
electrones en azul se movieron hacia el
oxígeno y formamos un enlace entre el
oxígeno en el etanol y este carbono así
que tenemos un enlace por aquí el
oxígeno sigue unido al hidrógeno y al
grupo de tilo
tiene una carga formal positiva muy bien
el siguiente paso sería la des protón
acción entonces paso 3 des protón acción
otra molécula de etanol entra y
funcionará como base un par de
electrones en el etanol toma este protón
dejando estos electrones con el oxígeno
dibujemos el resultado ahora tenemos
nuestro anillo
con un h del lado izquierdo y dos pares
de electrones libres en este oxígeno
pondré estos electrones en morado estos
electrones se quedaron con el oxígeno y
como pueden ver este es un emmy hace tal
es nuestro intermediario ok el siguiente
paso es la protón acción
paso 4 vamos a protón ar
este h de la izquierda una posibilidad
sería que un etanol protón hado funcione
como un ácido lo dibujaré por aquí
tenemos una carga formal positiva en
este oxígeno entonces un par de
electrones toma un protón dejando estos
electrones
hemos proto nado al h y es muy bueno
porque tendremos agua como nuestro grupo
saliente pongamos estos electrones en
rosa estos electrones tomaron un protón
y formaron este enlace y del lado
derecho tenemos a nuestro oxígeno con un
útil y dos pares de electrones libres
estos son los electrones en morado y
como hemos protón ado el h de la
izquierda el oxígeno tiene una carga
forma positiva observen que aquí se
esconde una molécula de agua el agua es
un excelente grupo saliente si estos
electrones en morado se mueven para
reformar el doble enlace estos
electrones se irán junto con el oxígeno
en el siguiente paso es
sería el paso 5 perdimos
h2o y nos queda nuestro anillo
unido con un doble enlace a este oxígeno
de aquí sale un grupo estilo aún tenemos
un par de electrones libres los
electrones en morado se movieron para
formar este doble enlace y tenemos una
carga formal positiva justo aquí si
dibujáramos las estructuras de
resonancia encontraríamos que este
carbono es muy electro físico entonces
en el siguiente paso el paso 6 ocurrirá
un ataque núcleo físico una molécula de
etanol entra y funcionará como núcleo
filo
este es nuestro etanol un par de
electrones libres ataca a nuestro
electro filo empujando estos electrones
hacia el oxigeno dibujemos lo que nos
queda muy bien ahora tenemos un oxígeno
por aquí unido a un hidrógeno y un grupo
de tilo de este lado tenemos otro
oxígeno con un grupo de tilos
y dos pares de electrones libres ya casi
terminamos el último paso el paso 7 es
la de protón acción lo único que hay que
hacer es quitar un protón para formar el
ac tal así que otra molécula de etanol
entra y funcionará como una base
un par de electrones toma al protón
dejando estos electrones con el oxígeno
finalmente dibujemos el producto
del lado izquierdo tenemos a nuestro
oxígeno con un grupo estilo y luego este
carbono está unido a otro oxígeno con un
grupo de tilo ahí está
estos electrones son los que se quedaron
con el oxígeno hemos formado nuestro
hace tal es un mecanismo largo y un poco
desafiante pero creo que es más fácil
así hagamos dos problemas rápidamente
echemos un vistazo a esta reacción
aquí tenemos acetaldehído y butanol esta
vez usaremos ácido tolueno sulfónico
como catalizador una de las cosas que
podemos hacer para cambiar el equilibrio
es incrementar la concentración de
acetaldehído si pensamos en la
estructura del producto podemos ver que
agregaremos esta porción de la molécula
de alcohol a este carbono y eso ocurrirá
dos veces entonces tenemos dos carbonos
y este carbono está unido a un oxígeno
al que se une la cadena de 4 carbonos 1
2 3 4 y este carbono está unido a otro
oxígeno
1 2 3 4
este sería nuestro hace tal
resaltemos algunos carbonos este carbono
sería este carbono de la derecha este es
el carbono que termina aquí y luego
cambiamos el color en la molécula de
butano y tenemos el oxígeno que
corresponde a este oxígeno y luego
tenemos 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 y 4 1 2 3 y 4
contar los carbonos es una técnica que
pueden usar en el ac tal que obtendrán
como producto final
hagamos una reacción más aquí tenemos
una zona de 4 carbonos butano
reaccionando con etilenglicol nuevamente
usaremos ácido tolueno sulfónico como
catalizador
debemos ver que es un poco diferente
porque ahora tenemos un día como uno de
nuestros reactivos anteriormente
teníamos butanol sólo un bache pero
ahora tenemos dos a veces ayuda que para
predecir el producto hagamos el
mecanismo rápidamente entonces el ácido
tolueno sulfónico nos ayudará a protón
ar el carbón hilo y después ocurrirá un
ataque núcleo físico uno de estos que
atacará aquí sin ver todo el mecanismo
que obviamente es un mecanismo
complicado podemos resumirlo en los
últimos pasos perdemos agua menos h2o y
esto nos da el intermediario en este
oxígeno tenemos una carga formal
positiva y luego dos carbonos por aquí y
nuestro
resaltemos algunos átomos ya teníamos
este oxígeno y como perdimos agua este
oxígeno corresponde a este también
tenemos un h que es este de aquí cuando
llegamos a este paso ocurre una reacción
intra molecular será un ataque núcleo
físico estos electrones atacan al
carbono y estos electrones se van con el
oxígeno así que nuestro producto final
será un compuesto cíclico tenemos 4
carbonos
este oxígeno 2 carbonos y otro oxígeno
que también se une a este carbono
resaltemos algunos carbonos este carbono
y este carbono corresponden a este y
este en nuestro producto final hemos
formado una zeta el cíclico fue un poco
más complicado que las reacciones
anteriores en el siguiente vídeo
veremos hace tales cíclicos funcionando
como grupos protectores